hello game developers and welcome back
to another exciting episode of game on i
am your host Todd Kerpelman on the play
games developer relations team and we're
going to jump right into this week's
episode so you know how last week we had
two presentations and we didn't really
have any news and updates well this time
around we're doing the reverse we don't
have any presentations but it's all news
and updates it's our exciting news and
updates episode and let's just get right
to it so first we're going to start by
talking about game services statistics
we've just started introducing some
basic game services stats into the
Google Play Developer console you can
see an example here we're looking at a
couple of sample games that we have
available on this front page here you
can see the number of people who have
signed in to your game using Play game
services you'll notice I don't don't get
confused by the the column header
players that's a little misleading this
isn't people who are playing your game
but players who have signed into game
services with your game the actual
number of people playing your game is
probably going to be larger than this
also if you go into your achievement
screen within game services you will now
see a percentage complete staff these
are the number of players who have
signed in who have earned this
achievement so this is a really good way
to look and see if there are any
achievements that are too difficult to
get so we're looking at brunos sample
game here firewall defense and you can
see that there are a number of
achievements where the percent complete
is basically zero and so he's probably
made those achievements too hard this is
a common trap for all your game
developers you play your game for weeks
on end do you understand how it works
inside and out and you know achievements
that seemed really easy for you to get
her very difficult for your average
player so this is a good way to go back
and just kind of sanity check your
assumptions and see if those
achievements really are as easier is
this difficult as you thought they were
in addition you will now be able to see
the number of unique players who have
submitted a score to each of your leader
boards and this is
useful if say you have different
leaderboards for different levels you
suddenly have an idea of how many people
have completed each one of your
different levels because obviously you
can see the number of score completions
for each one of those so I know that by
the by themselves these stats are you
know they're interesting but they might
be data that you already have if you're
using any kind of third-party analytics
tool already but you know it's I think
maybe the interesting point here is that
we have all the plumbing now attached so
that we can get data from the Play game
services down to the developer console
and up to you the game developer so what
we have here is a pretty nice start and
more importantly we have a nice
foundation for us to start showing you a
lot more interesting statistics
regarding game services so you know now
that now we've got kind of all the
plumbing hooked up we've got a few basic
things in there expect to see some more
stats from us in the future and so I
don't know I think this is kind of cool
hopefully you do too in addition we've
just launched game insights on the
developer console we call it game
insights because mistakes that you're
making sounds kind of negative but
that's kind of what these are these are
our way of alerting you to errors in
your game that you might not notice as a
developer one of the most important
being that your game has exceeded the
rate limit for some reason you're
calling achievements that increment too
often or there's some bug in your in
your program that you know calling some
some method on a loop that it shouldn't
be in the past these are very hard for
for you to detect right you have to kind
of look for status codes being returned
from your client and you know maybe log
those somewhere or something on this is
happening in the wild it's very hard for
you as a developer to know what's going
on so now if we notice that your app is
getting throttled we immediately give
you an alert in the developer console so
look for those in addition you can look
for I think probably our most common
error that we see happening with game
developers is that you have published
you an update to your game but you
forgot to hit publish in the game
services section what that means is that
you've got games out there that are
trying to for instance
complete and achievement or sentence
scores to a leaderboard and your game
services are not published and the
system says oh wait you know I don't
want to make these available yet and it
rejects those calls what I think is
actually particularly tricky about this
particular error is that game services
will allow calls from anybody who is on
the tester list which probably includes
you the game developer so you might have
people saying hey I can turn this
achievement what's wrong and you try it
out you say it looks fine to me that's
because you're on the tester list you're
able to submit for complete achievements
to to non-published achievements and
leaderboards and normal players cannot
and so this error does get does happen a
lot and a lot of developers miss this
and so now we surface this as well in
the developer console this happens to
you and there's a third error a little
less common but there are times when
your game tries to unlock an achievement
or submit a score to a leaderboard and
the ID is incorrect and again that's
probably something where you would get
back an error in the client but it's a
little hard for for that error to get
sent to you the developer or at least it
was in the past now when we notice this
is happening a lot we will alert you and
you'll start to see okay my application
apparently is trying to unlock this this
achievement that doesn't exist maybe I
did a copy and paste error or something
you can start looking into that so go to
base be sure to go and visit the
developer console look for these alerts
they will come in very handy in addition
we are now giving you twice the cloud so
we have the service cloud save generally
designed for games which is a very
simple hey just say my data to the cloud
load it somewhere else it's great if
you've got developers or if you've got
players that are playing your game on
multiple devices they can carry their
progress from one device to the next and
in the past we had four slots of 128 k
available to you and now check out check
out these effects BAM we are moving to
four slots or of 256k each so that's
twice the cloud that's you know thousand
24k total hopefully that's that's enough
for you to save a pretty decent save
game file
so make use of that and finally there is
a new Google+ iOS SDK this is not
specifically related to game services
this is related to anything you would
want to do with Google+ so you non game
developers as well if you're looking to
share anything on google+ this is
relevant to you too there are a number
enhancements to this sdk but the biggest
thing you'll notice is the native share
box it used to be that if you want to
share something from a game or an
application to Google+ you had to
basically switch out of your app or your
game and over into a browser Mobile
Safari something like that so that you
know you could you could share on
Google+ and it wasn't a great experience
right I mean you left your app to go
into a browser so that you could post
this thing so now the new experience got
some more effects there is much nicer
this is a native share box so it
basically pops up within your
application user doesn't have to leave
it they don't have to to swap out and
they can share directly through Google+
from there in addition this native share
box has some features that let you
upload and share a photo or a video this
is great for for you game developers you
can take a screenshot of your game and
you can add that in to the native share
box and and share right there so you
know it makes for a much more
interesting post when when someone can
share exactly the cool thing that's
happening in their game when they share
this stuff so we will update our sample
code to show you how to do that make
sure to view the Google+ documentation
it basically gives you all the code
snippets you'll you'll need to get that
working also watch out by the way there
i think for new frameworks that you're
going to have to add into your
application that you didn't have to
before again all that is available on
the Google+ documentation side of things
so if you want more information you can
check that out and I believe that
concludes this week's episode of game on
go go to your developer console check
out those stats I think it's pretty
interesting and we will see you in a
couple weeks thanks game developers